- Yo, yo, yo!
Snapchat Guru Molly...
(tires screeching)
Hawkey, here!
I love myself a lot,
even in the face of
crippling self-doubt,
and a bitch mother.
To prove how much I love myself,
I'm gonna hit up my favorite
date night restaurant alone.
Because when you're
comfortable in your own skin,
you can be comfortable anywhere.
Let's go!
- How many?
- Table for one.
Oh, no, you can leave those.
(both chuckling)
- Uh, may I get you
something to drink?
- Oh, yes, your best house red.
Oh, make that two!
(French dinner music)
Oh, thank god.
Somebody's meeting me here.
(coughing)
I've got bread throat.
Bread throat!
Hey guys, well, I'm
having the best time.
My food just got here,
and lucky me, I get to eat it
with my best friend, myself.
(gasps)
Oh my god, it's my
ex-boyfriend, Paolo.
Are you kidding me right now?
(slams phone down)
- Molly?
- Oh, Paolo!
(laughing uncomfortably)
What is up, my brother?
- I'm just grabbing a bite to
eat with my friend, Deanna.
- Oh, wow, that's fun for her!
- Yeah, it's so
healthy of you to
come to our special place alone.
I'm really proud of you.
- Me?
Oh, no, you're hilarious.
You just missed my
boyfriend, Gupta.
He's a doctor, so he was paged.
By Olivia Munn,
who is his patient!
Her back is F'd, you know?
Anyway, I love him,
Olivia Munn loves him,
so everything's great.
Everything's really, really
great with me right now,
at this time of my life.
- Okay, well, it's
really good to see you.
- [Molly] You too.
Well, that went drunk.
Great, it went great.
I'm drunk, though.
(wheezing)
Oh, you should have seen how
comfortable I was
in my own skin.
(gagging)
Too spicy!